hi I'm Mark and I'm the CEO and founder
of tungle uh we recently made a really
cool update to tungle me and I've heard
really positive things from all of our
users so if you don't have it you should
have it but what I wanted to talk to you
about is uh about this little change
that we did over the weekend uh which I
think could have a good and positive
impact of how you use tungle so let me
talk to you a bit about it the way
tungle worked uh so far was that when
you're creating a meeting invitation to
people tungle is the one that sends the
email out to all your attendees so that
possibility is still there but what
we've added is we're giving you the
option to also get a URL instead that or
a link that what you can do is you can
take and put it in your emails or Skype
it or email it to whoever you want so
let me show you a bit about how that
works so I want to schedule a meeting
with someone and here I've got a button
uh to schedule a meeting this is my
tungle account so call it a lunch
meeting uh and let's say I wanted to be
at one of those uh cool restaurants
around the office here in Montreal
called holder so we're doing a little
Google mashup gives me the address and
then I get to invite people I'm going to
invite my brother um he works for the
ministry of Justice here in Canada and
there uh this is kind of the cool part
here I can get to propose as many times
as I want for the meeting or for the
lunch and um I can go across different
days and so on so here you go I propose
times and now here is where things are a
bit different so like before you can
have tungle send the invitation out for
you or what you can do is you can also
get a link a URL that you can then Skype
to so on so I'm choosing this option and
I'm clicking on create invitation so now
you can see that it gave me a URL that
can just copy and I can decide to Skype
it or email it or do whatever I want
with it
so uh a little small change I I can say
but could have a big impact of how you
use tongle so looking forward to getting
your feedback in the meantime uh enjoy
tongling and uh stay tuned for lots more
so have happy holidays